que l'assemblée nationale salue le
courage et la détermination des douze
athlètes skieuses et victimes
d'agressions sexuelles
aujourd'hui c'est un grand pas ici au
québec pour que nos enfants plus grands
vire dans un environnement sportif
sécuritaire sans abus pour la première
fois depuis trop longtemps la colère si
mousse nous voulons donner le courage à
chaque personne qui le désire de trouver
sa voie
aujourd'hui marque une journée très
important dans le sport parce qu'à
partir de maintenant nos jeunes pourront
exercer le sport de façon saine et
sécuritaire
ils seront en mesure de réaliser leur
rêve et leur plein potentiel
votre écoute vos thèmes enchères dans
nos coeurs j'espère de tout coeur que
les autres provinces et le gouvernement
fédéral suivront les traces du québec
pour rendre l'espoir 5 sécuritaire et
sans abus nous les femmes ne nous
soumettrons plus à ce rapport de pouvoir
c'est ça qui est en train de se passer
alors est-ce qu'il faut agir
certainement est-ce qu'il faut dénoncer
certainement mais pourquoi ces femmes
n'ont pas dénoncé depuis vingt ans parce
que la société n'était pas prête pour
des gestes au quotidien lorsqu'on est
ministre ou député dans une assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui moi c'est une
journée dont je me souviendrai vous êtes
tous des femmes exceptionnelles forte
courageuse ensemble formant une équipe
unie et sans vous je ne serais pas ici
aujourd'hui
merci d'être à mes côtés je vous en
serai toujours reconnaissant